[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[Приазов'я,
село Перекоп]
У нас у селищі проживає дев'ятнадцять осіб.
З них двом по вісімдесят шість років.
[Юрій Мосьпан
Фермер]
Шістьом за сімдесять.
Решта — мікс лишається.
Мені сорок п'ять років, Василю сорок, Олені менше.
Кому було куди тікати, той утік.
А мені не було куди, тому довелось тут розживатися.
Хліб нам привозять раз на тиждень.
Усі беруть багато.
Із цим поки проблем немає.
Дітей до школи автобус
забирає в центральному селищі.
У принципі нема на що жалітись,
головне, що війни немає.
Земля у нас — здебільшого солончаки,
двадцять відсотків солончаків.
Світло-каштановий ґрунт —
зона ризикованого землеробства.
Це найкращі майстри,
пропрацювали в радгоспі 20 років.
Вони найкращі спеціалісти.
Льоша, пішли свій трактор покажеш!
Він доглядає за ним, як за жінкою.
Пан Олександр — це мозковий центр.
Інженер-електрик, але книжки ночами читає.
Але він не любить себе афішувати.
Але голова 60-го розміру.
Стільки мізків, енциклопедія відпочиває.
Усі фермери мисливці.
Мисливство — це наше все.
Пішли зайців постріляти, то заодно
обговорити поточні проблеми.
Коли Майдан почався,
на полюванні ледь не бились.
Кожен має власну думку.
Кажуть, що район сепаратистів.
Але наш район теж строкатий.
Одні за, інші проти.
Та й вся Україна така.
Пшениця, ячмінь, насіння, все.
Більш нічого такого не вирощуємо.
Ми ж не круті фермери.
Ми середні.
Дрібні фермери.
Одні люди з металобрухту роблять речі.
Інші — металобрухт з речей.
Ми робимо з металобрухту речі.
Він ось їздить.
Раніше був колгосп імені Леніна.
Був клуб — місце, де зустрічались.
Туди приїжджав кінотеатр кожної суботи.
Усі приходили туди дивитись кіно, спілкуватись.
Магазин був.
Був дитячий садок і трирічна школа.
У неділю була традиція в селі:
всі чоловіки приходили в клуб,
грали хто в більярд, хто в карти, хто в доміно.
Увечері напивались, бились і розходились.
Тут зберігається посівний матеріал.
Тут ячмінь зберігається.
Там пшениця.
А клуб — це ангар, узимку ремонт робимо.
Оце вона стоїть, туди рундук ставиться.
Машина задом під'їжджає і висипає по-тихеньку.
Якби знали, що буде стабільність,
то могли б будувати, гроші вкладати.
А так...
Добре, що нема кому красти.
Все підперте, ось мій склад під насіння,
зерно всю зиму пролежало, а ніхто ні мішка не взяв.
Коли приїжджають місцеві геничани,
вони знаходять порожню хату,
купують її за 1000 гривень,
щоб розібрати на будматеріали.
Ми просто вирішили їх скуповувати.
Ось людина, олігарх, дві хати в селі.
Одна хата своя, а другу за скільки взяв?
За 4000 гривень.
Купив хату, щоб тільки не валяти.
Це теж зробили, як то кажуть, щоб було.
Шкода хату валяти.
Воно, знаєш, як добре, кум приїде з полювання,
сіли, дрова закинули, і краса.
Заходьте.
Ось закинутий дім, дивись,
яка якість, різьба по дереву.
Фільончасті двері.
Якщо в кожному селищі є якась установа,
є господар, тоді буде селище.
Якщо в селищі не буде установи, а буде,
як зараз роблять, на 20 сіл один господар,
тоді господаря взагалі не буде, а буде безлад.
Ось був тут колгосп ім. Леніна,
було все, і комори, і винні заводи, і город був.
Це був внутрішній організм.
Зробили одне селище,
центральне, п'ять...
Так ці п'ять і пов'яли, а одне центральне лишилось.
Це взагалі ганьба для України.
Такого не можна показувати.
Якщо так розібратися, то люди скажуть,
наскільки ми хамуваті і недоглянуті.
Є ж гарна картинка, а тут її нема.
Якщо подати в гарних кольорах,
що тут люди, можна сказати, патріоти.
Ось він патріот,
я в певній мірі патріот.
Навіщо мені цей Перекоп, у мене в місті все є.
Але мені в місті стіни давлять.
А сюди приїду, походжу...
Ну не знаю...
Я щасливий, коли у мене всі здорові.
А багатий, коли в кишені є пачка цигарок.
Тоді я багатий.
Більше мені нічого не треба.
[Оператор
Дмитро Охріменко]
[Монтаж
Марія Теребус]
[Музика
Blooms Corda]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]